en tiempos normales las calles de
beijing estarían llenas de gente para la
fiesta nacional del trabajo pero este
año los lugares públicos se han quedado
casi sin turistas por el temor al
aumento de los contagios por kobe 19 los
negocios han sufrido un duro golpe y
esta vendedora no se siente optimista
genial las ventas fueron buenas el año
pasado pero este año han sido miserables
muchas de las autoridades locales en
diferentes partes del territorio chino
están pidiendo a los residentes que
limiten los viajes por el país china
mantiene su política de kobe cero y con
la última oleada de la variante omicron
decenas de ciudades del país están bajo
bloqueo total o parcial la propia
capital ha implementado nuevas
restricciones a pesar de sólo registrar
unas pocas docenas de casos al día
los restaurantes permanecen cerrados
mientras que los parques temáticos y los
lugares de ocio están a la mitad de su
capacidad beijing quiere evitar un
cierre total como el de shanghai
mediante una campaña de pruebas masivas
la mayor parte de los 25 millones de
residentes del centro económico llevan
ya más de un mes confinados en sus casas
lo que ha provocado protestas en parte
de la
la ciudad registró 10.000 casos el
viernes pero por primera vez no hubo
nuevos contagios fuera del sistema de
cuarentena es probable que las últimas
restricciones supongan un nuevo golpe
para la economía del país